i never lie but i think a lot more
people should lie you could look cool
yeah uh i don't think more people should
lie because as somebody who used to lie
it's uh it's really exhausting what did
you lie
about feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right i uh i want to talk about this
open c thing i'm laughing about it but
before we get into that people like
story stuff let me quote not a story but
do you know who laird hamilton is
surfer
yeah so he uh he like is like when you
think of the word like surfer hunk he's
like the guy you like think of right
like blind he's like kind of
the most famous one i think and he's a
little bit older now right
yeah he's in his 50s he could be as old
as 60 but uh he's 57 and
there's two amazing things about him
the first he has this thing called
layered superfood have you heard of that
no
okay it's interesting for a bunch of
reasons the first reason why it's
interesting is laird is interesting to
me he's basically so laird hamilton was
a surfer in hawaii he had a troubled
childhood but he dedicated his life to
surfing he says that he might be a
little autistic and that he like focuses
on a goal incredibly uh like he he'll
achieve it no matter what he obsesses so
for a long time he was obsessed with
finding the biggest wave he invented toe
in surfing and then eventually he got
into uh health and he got obsessed with
eliminating sugar eliminating flour and
just being very very very healthy and so
eventually he launched a company called
layered superfood and he's obsessed with
coffee he drinks tons of caffeine loves
coffee and he didn't want to use like
almond milk or oatly or anything like
that and so he invents
this thing called layered superfood it
starts with a creamer now they sell a
bunch of different stuff a bunch of
different creamers a bunch of different
health foods
it seems legitimate i'm gonna buy some
of them some of it because uh
it does look i like him and i like the
idea of what it promises although i
don't know the science behind it but the
second second reason why it's
interesting it went public it's publicly
traded it went public with like 18
million in revenue currently has a
market cap 163 million dollars revenue
of like 50 i think
uh but kind of cool right and laird
interests me because he's kind of like
there's no such thing as a perfect human
but he checks all the boxes in terms of
he's doing getting a bunch of stuff so
physically fit great he seems
emotionally incredibly healthy very
stable like when he talks to him he
seems very wise and like he understands
uh how to treat people got a great
family it seems and now financially very
successful adventurous this guy's my
hero uh but i don't know if he had ever
i thought it was interesting that they
took the company public
yeah that sounds also just did it take
it public in the us or somewhere else
here it's uh
where it's on it's on the new york stock
stock exchange it's called layered
superfood
doesn't it seem too small it's like a
penny stock like what is the market cap
of it if it has 18 million in revenue it
doesn't have 18 million in revenue now
maybe what's it have now you could look
it up like 40 or 50. it ha it's market
cap right now is 163. its highest ever
was uh two times that
interesting okay uh and yeah i'm kind of
like you where
there's something you know some um
like if you're just like a normal
instagram influencer and you're like
talking some product
uh or whoever you're whoever you're me
you're you're just like normal person
and you're you're talking some product
it's like okay
you know you probably tried to do a good
job with this but like this is a
business for you and you're doing this
for the business
and
then when you see someone like laird
hamilton who's like walked the walk for
like i don't know how many years you
guys like 50 something years old and you
see he's just like ripped absolutely
ripped at that age you kind of know that
he's lived a certain lifestyle
and um i have a higher level of trust
when this guy's selling me a tea or a
you know a breakfast waffle
keto breakfast waffles or a creamer or
whatever this stuff is that he has
i do feel like i trust a lot more than
uh
you know whatever ryan gosling's gin or
something you know like where it's like
clearly just celebrity face plus generic
product equals like branded product now
the second thing i wanted to ask you
okay so
when i look at this guy i've been
reading a lot about him i've been
obsessing a little bit about him and
i've been watching all this stuff he's
always working out and for the past
maybe four months i've been working out
really hard i'll do like maybe 10
workouts a week so sometimes two days
and i'm always sweating yeah i'm moving
a lot and i started thinking about this
because there's this thing that trump
said and it's always stuck with me and
and for some reason the way that he said
it
i just it never went away and someone
was like this is right after his
physical
and they go trump why don't you exercise
he's like it's a waste of time i don't
want to waste my energy and they're like
what he goes yeah look like i only have
a limited amount of energy in my
lifetime
my my body's like a battery i'm not
gonna use my battery on exercise when i
could be using it building businesses or
doing whatever and i have no idea what
the truth is of this but it got me
thinking
i paraphrased it but yeah so if you
google like trump
health battery
we call it like it's like trump's
battery theory or something like that
and i have no idea the validity of this
this could be the stupidest thing ever
i've i don't know
it just
i just thought it was hilarious when he
said it but it got me thinking like
i read david's goggins biography and
like the dude's sweating all the time
and like
can
like
let me read this out let me read this
out
uh trump gave up athletics after college
because he believed the human body was
like a battery with a finite amount of
energy which exercise only depleted he
said
uh
what did he say he goes
i don't know here's a scientist
a better analogy would be it's like a
fire that you continue to fuel with more
coal or wood you need to continue to add
fuel or your flame will die this is true
whether you're exercising or not simply
by existing we're burning energy okay i
don't know what this guy's talking about
so well i was thinking about it i'm like
if our if our life only if our hearts
this trump battery thing is too
ridiculous i can't get over it and it's
great right
that's great
a possible val this is like i walked in
on my sister once she was supposed to be
studying and she was i walked into her
room and she was just laying down
sleeping and i was like oh my wake up
like you're supposed to be my mom like i
was a little kid my mom i sent me in to
be like is she studying for the test i
was like mom say you're supposed to be
sitting for the test she's like no no
i'm reviewing in my head and i was like
oh sorry sorry sorry and i went back to
my mom and i was like she's reviewing
she just closed her eyes to review
like she was definitely just sleeping
that's what trump's battery thing is to
me it's like some [__] excuse for
not wanting to exercise
yeah well i i was thinking i'm like what
again i'm an idiot i know nothing but
like if your heart can only beat some
number of beats throughout your lifetime
am i wasting it by just like being
sweaty all the time and working out all
the time and i uh i was thinking about
this layered habited guy and i'm like
dude maybe you should just go for walks
instead of like like how much exercise
like do we actually need
you know like when i say david gaga's
like running hundreds of miles and he's
like on his instagram he's always
working out it's like
i i just i want to start reading about
like where where's the threshold of
where it actually doesn't matter
because yeah well okay i i think you
know here's my my very basic theory
which is
it's not like a
okay it's like a battery but batteries
can be recharged and whatnot uh it's
basically right your heart and other
parts of your body are muscles and the
muscles can grow stronger with you know
exercise and then they develop or they
can grow weaker without use and so not
using them doesn't just preserve your
precious energy marbles and you're going
to go live till you're 200 it's uh it's
that if you build your muscles up
including your heart your brain by you
know studying or cardiovascular exercise
you're going to get more out of it
you're going to be able to do more now
plus it'll be able to like last longer
through atrophy in your life i hear you
but but when i see laird hamilton at 57
and i'm like working my butt off right
now i'm like he all this stuff is about
recovery he talks about recovery he
talks about how this helps and i'm like
well just like do less and don't you
don't need to recover
just like do less stuff you know like
like okay look at laird hamilton and
then look at trump and just look at
their results and say which body do you
ultimately want do you want that guy's
body and energy or do you want this
guy's body and energy and i think it'll
guide you down the right path like i'm
just saying i'm thinking out loud here
this is something that i'm questioning
myself like how hard am i going to go
and like why do i want to recover all
the time like i just i there's there
should be no need to recover all the
time um do you want to you want to
before we get into topics do you want to
do you want to talk about this uh nft
thing or no so i just finished up my
crypto week which was i talked about the
last pod basically i took a week of time
cancelled all my other meetings i said
i'm going to go into i'm going to go
neck deep in crypto what does that mean
all these ideas i knew about but
basically i wanted to go play with i
wanted to go do right so if you think
about like how you can participate in
things you can sit on the sidelines and
watch
you can kind of uh you can kind of jump
in and be a player but not not the
driver you can participate or you can
create and that's when you're really
hands-on you're actually making [__]
happen so i wanted to create as much as
possible this week i had already been on
the sidelines watching i'd already been
a participant there's a whole bunch of
protocols and tools and ideas that i'd
never done so anyways i had this idea
and tell me what you think so i think we
should create an nft and i s you know
side note i created it it's ready to go
if i just push this button um push it
okay push it okay great so i created
this nft called five minutes of fame and
what it is it's a one-of-one token
that anybody can own that gives you the
right to five minutes of air time
on our show
now or anytime in the future you can
hold this thing for five years if you
think we're gonna be
massive bit much bigger in five years
just hold it it'll appreciate but once
you use it and the way to use it is you
burn it right so you own this token and
it's only one of one and when you want
to use it you send it to our wallet and
that when you send it to our wallet
we've received it that tells us this
token has been burned the five minutes
of fame now you can come on the show and
you can hang with us talk with us and
you can do whatever you want if you want
to just repeat the name of your company
for five straight minutes annoying but
doable you could do it to promote your
[__] that way if you want to come
brainstorm with us we like them ask
questions you can do whatever you want
as long as it's obviously not like you
know vulgar or hateful or whatever not
some like uncool [__] you know like can
they can they sell it
they can sell it yeah so say somebody so
i've started the floor price
at 0.5 eth right so less than one ether
i wanted to see how high this ends up
going so i'm going to start the bidding
there it's going to run for one week
after this episode airs
and when it's going to run for one week
and so anybody can go on openc right now
and i gotta figure out how you find it
it's called five minutes of fame my
first million
and uh but
i'll tweet it out too you gotta spell my
first million it's just mfm now yeah
yeah i'm gonna i'll i'm gonna change the
title of it i'm also gonna put it in the
show notes of this description so you go
to openc if you don't know how to do
nfts in openc
there's a hard way to start but if you
kind of know what this stuff's all about
you know what we're doing here what
we're doing is we're basically saying
look money has always been like a
frozen block of time right i go do a
bunch of work
i put in time i get money i go give that
money to a restaurant i say hey thaw
this frozen block of time out and uh you
go work for a bit you you go you go
spend some time for me make some food
for me and then you know like that's how
money trades hands it's just frozen
blocks of time so what i did was i just
took five minutes of air time and i
froze it and i said anybody can buy this
you can hold it you could use it or you
could sell it you could flip it and i
want to see what happens with this thing
over time and i want to see if who buys
it i want to see what they do with it i
want to see if they use it or if they
wait because our show's growing like 20
percent month over month 25 month over
month so you know you wait a year and
all of a sudden you're gonna have it's a
bigger show it's a big it's a it's more
valuable air time for you to go on and
by the way we don't take sponsors
anymore right we sold the show to a
hubspot they're the only sponsors if you
wanted to come sponsor a show and buy
some air time you literally couldn't
right now
this is the only way and so i this is an
experiment i don't know what's going to
happen but i'm excited about it it was
one of my things just make and mint an
nft of my own that was part of my crypto
week
all right great i'll share it yeah i'll
i'm going to wait for you to tweet it
and then i'll i'll take lead on how you
write it and then okay sounds good
all right let's see what happens
that's awesome uh yeah okay so what do
you want to do let's do this let's do
this in order so let's let's first do
another story let's do this guy
who took our stripe for vice idea which
was a long time ago so he's i don't know
i don't know if i buy it okay
we'll we'll preface it with this
might be total [__] right sounds a
little made up sounds a little bit
fanfictiony but uh i'm gonna give him
the benefit of the doubt so okay so so
we said this idea
i don't even know how long ago maybe a
year ago which was uh my friend
our mutual friend sully had this idea
and i i brought it to the podcast which
was
uh stripe for vice verse ventures right
so what does that mean so stripe is a
payment processing
uh platform so if you want to take
payments on your website you use stripe
but the problem is stripe has like many
payment processors like paypal like
others terms and conditions which
basically say you can't use this if
you're
cannabis if you're crypto if you're um
you know porn if you're all these
different use cases and so um the idea
was to build a product you know clone
the product quality and developer
friendliness of stripe
but have your terms and conditions open
and this is like kind of a strategic
move because
one of the best ways to compete against
the big monopolies
is not to do what they're not doing now
right a lot of people do this they pitch
us an idea that says oh you know
you know twitch isn't focused on this
right now music so we're gonna do twitch
for music it's like yeah but you know
they could if they wanted to yeah
especially if you proved it out they
could do that or
facebook doesn't have you know doesn't
let you see this so i'm going to add
this feature okay but they could easily
add that whereas
whereas these are
they can't do it because it would go
against it would threaten their core
business so stripe can't type might even
the the ceo might say hey i think
cannabis is great but he can't do it
because it's going to threaten his
relationships with his banking partners
and so it'll put the core big valuable
business at risk which is why you're
actually safe going and pursuing this
because they're just not gonna do it in
the same way that um
like only fans is safe because it's
something instagram will never do
instagram could have all those same
models on there but they will never
release this feature which lets you pay
for kind of this locked
locked not safe for content because it
threatens their advertising business
with their clean with coca-cola and
whoever else
and so
terms and conditions is actually an
amazing way to compete against big
successful incumbents go do what they
explicitly say they won't do
um and they can't do so okay anyways
there's this guy on twitter
the name is skyler mr schuyler is his
hand
and he says public service announcement
for all the my first million pod fans
from stealing ideas from the pod don't
play short-term games because take it
from me i took their stripe for vice
idea
i grew it to a business doing over 400
000 a month in 60 days in less than 60
days
and then i got pushed out by literal
gangsters i wish i was joking here's the
story anyway so he tells a story he
basically says
he looked at stripes terms of service
and it said
you can't do get rich quick schemes you
can't do cannabis you can't do a
mug shot publication or pay to remove
websites so he's like great that's my
prospecting list i will just make a list
of these companies that do exactly those
things and i'll start cold emailing like
crazy he's like and then in parallel i
went i went to galileo and synapse and i
tried to find payment providers
infrastructure companies that would let
me do this they both said no so then i
called some like new fintech companies
they also said no it's like but then i
went and i found this small like
canadian bank that i had used in the
past like a local bank and it turns out
for a monthly fee they'll work with it
will work with me great and so then he
sets it up and
he starts getting like online
dispensaries cannabis companies start
using them and this is where it gets a
little bit weird like that business is
working
but one of the dispensary companies i
guess like that he knew
that was super profitable like they
needed help and he's like oh they asked
me to come on board and i didn't really
understand this bar did you get this he
like basically joins their company
uh he joins their company or something
like that and um
anyways it starts making 400 000 a month
and he's like you know
i moved into a dope condo in vancouver
downtown vancouver i fly first class to
turks and caicos i spent 13 000 a night
at this hotel and you know he goes the
girl i'm seeing is now running around
with the fake senate a new set of fake
titty somewhere i wish i had saved this
money but instead i was spending it
right and then he's like
so this is where this part of the story
sounded a little unbelievable because i
don't think you would even be balling
out that much on this small this little
amount of money but i guess some people
just don't don't say it so maybe
anyways he um
he says you know the company that they
were buying product from
which is like a publicly listed company
is run by crooked
gangsters they started harassing me and
my family blah blah blah i ended up
paying them
i don't know
i met up with them with a bag of cash
and i told them to leave my family alone
and i left the business forever
and uh yeah that's my story of you know
i i've traded peace of mind i traded my
money for for peace of not peace of mind
and here's what i love
subscribe to my newsletter
i so i'm i'm good i googled this guy a
bunch
uh he i think he's full of it this is
just maybe i i think that maybe there's
like some truth here like maybe he tried
to start this maybe like someone sketchy
emailed him
and that's about it
yeah
it definitely seems
like the bag of cash i met them in a
park and they told me uh are you lying
bro are you lying is this
is this you lying i think you're lying
so i don't know i don't know if he's
lying or not he needs to show some
receipts if he wants us to uh to fully
vouch for it but i thought it's an
entertaining story nonetheless
i think that actually like more people
should lie to be honest i don't know why
more people don't lie whenever i'm on
the internet and i'm like talking about
stuff anonymously i always tell the
truth like like what a great zag
everybody else is all about honesty you
know what
lying underwriting i never lie a lot
like i'll comment like in different
posts and they'll say like like just
ridiculous stuff and i'm like no no like
i've done this before like here like
just like on a random fox news thread or
or on reddit i'm like no that's not true
for this reason that reason and i'll
explain my personal experience i never
lie but i think a lot more people should
lie you could look cool
yeah i don't think more people should
lie because as somebody who used to lie
it's uh it's really exhausting what did
you lie about
dude i used to like i used to exaggerate
so you know i used to do everything that
i wouldn't call a lot but if you look
back it's a lie right like i would
exaggerate or somebody thinks something
and i like let it run i'm like oh yeah
i'm not going to correct that i'm going
to let you run with this mistake and
assumption i didn't lie you got it wrong
and i didn't i didn't correct you that's
not my fault and so there's all these
little things like that or
i don't know like it would just be where
it was always
like insecurity so it's like you know if
i wanted to seem cooler smarter richer
more successful than i was
i was willing to kind of like embellish
or lead somebody on it the wrong way or
whatever and um and maybe i still do
sometimes i don't really know i don't
want to say like i've completely gotten
rid of it i can't remember the last time
i did that but i definitely remember a
point in time about five years ago where
i was like i'm just not gonna lie
anymore
i'm just gonna actually say what the
situation is and then i'm gonna let the
chips fall where they may and it was so
freeing and uh relief it was like just
relief because um somebody who said this
once they they go
like in programming there's this thing
where like any time an application slows
down one of the one of the reasons that
people will say if you talk to
programmers they're like oh
you know it's like a threading problem
or like there's a multi-thread problem
and what it means is basically there's
like multiple processes running at once
and they start to like use up all the
memory of the computer and basically
that's what happens in your head when
you lie is your brain has to keep two
threads open there's the thread that
basically is like
what i said and then there's the truth
and you constantly have to keep track of
what you said versus the truth
in order to like maintain the lie
and so that becomes like having two
processes running in your head just
drains you of energy is what i found so
i don't lie anymore but i think you're
right that in the short term
there's a big benefit to lying um which
is like
you know like most people can't figure
it out most people don't don't check you
even the people who do check you just
like their voice is like small compared
to the most people that will just take
in a fake value right like fake news i
think is popular for a reason like i've
done stuff like i've bought i bought my
car so i bought my car it was a it was
over it was six figures and i bought it
i saw a picture of it online and it was
like three hours away and i called the
guy and i go hey what's up uh you got
this car i go great i'll send you the
money right now will you drive it over
in a few days and i just why it was all
done on myself on the car i just wired
on the money and he brought it to me a
days later
and i've done that so many times
motorcycles vehicles i buy [__] all the
time and i'll just say like yeah i'll
just give you the money now don't sell
it and
so many people are honest and i'm in my
head i'm like everything would be so
much more profitable but way worse if
like you can get away with lying you can
you can totally get away with it and
most people never do it and it does
shock me
uh
all right
and we'll end that segment there um all
right let's go let's do another one
uh you want to do an idea i got
something yes yeah okay so this idea
this comes from ben so ben gave me this
idea today
and i like i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
burn you hard on this one so keep going
okay good good um figs for construction
okay so for those who don't know what
figs is figs is a a brand that came out
that basically was making like cooler
looking scrubs medical scrubs so the
stuff that doctors and nurses wear those
little blue
outfits that were like kind of
traditionally like well it's all blue
the same color of blue they're all kind
of baggy and they all kind of look
shitty and here you have these people
that are like working really hard they
wear this stuff all day
it's kind of like their identity it's
like their uniform and um and they make
good money there doctors make good money
and yeah why are they wearing this stuff
and so
figs came out i think it started with
nurses and they just started making like
better fitting so it didn't look as
baggy and loose a little more flattering
and they had some different colors and
patterns that you could have for your
scrubs and we we talked about them right
i think right when they got going
yeah like pretty early on we talked
about them and fast forward now a couple
we're two years into the pod um
things is a public company now wow seven
billion dollars
seven billion dollar market cap
if you go read any of the articles it's
like why figs is the next lululemon why
it's the next nike why figs is a
starbucks for scrubs it's like they just
put companies sexy brand sphinx is
several years old i think fig's like
probably eight years old or something uh
figs found good let's see and the woman
who started it does not look like the
woman who would start she i mean she
looks like a like a like a fashion like
a supermodel
oh really okay that's like i would have
thought like i guess a nurse in my head
like she's wearing like fancy ass [__]
in her picture so so figgs is yeah i
think i got it right eight years old i
went public at 4 billion it's now 7
billion
and um
and i think what what is it so
so there's this guy thomas tull who i
didn't know but he's the founder of
legendary pictures
he had sold that to a chinese company
for three and a half billion dollars
and uh and he was the majority
shareholder and so i think he owned 58
of figs at the time of ipo which is kind
of a ludicrous amount of a public
company to own
and then uh you know is this the person
you talk about heather heather hassan
yeah you see like in a lot of her photos
she looks like she's like i was like uh
she just looks like a like a
she's in what's the equivalent of gq for
women i don't know i'm an idiot but you
know what i mean vogue like she's
wearing vogue i don't know she's wearing
she just look i would just imagine
someone wearing a nurse's outfit
he put 50 million in in 2018 and became
a majority owner so 2018
is when he puts 50 million in become
buys you know 58 percent three years
later goes public at a 4.4 billion
valuation so his 50 million turned into
2.2 million of equity value so
good on him um okay so anyways so
basically
the uh okay so the idea here so figs
seven billion dollar market cap i think
it does just over a quarter billion
dollars so over 250 million dollars of
revenue a year i couldn't find the exact
number quickly during my last minute
research here but
here's the idea figs for construction so
how many other industries have a large
workforce
that kind of needs specialty
clothing for doing what they do
and today they have like a generic
default and um and maybe you can build a
sexier ddc brand like figs for
construction so this is the idea um this
is the idea thanks for construction
you know construction workers have a lot
of different things that they wear
listen i know that you don't know who
dolly parton is and you're just so
disconnected to like normal amer
americans it's called carhartt you dummy
this is a thing i've been wearing this
for years and it's awesome google
carhartt
obviously there's brands that do durable
you know rugged wear no carhartt is like
i remember as a kid like we used to go
to the hardware that sounds like i'm
real redneck but i'm not that redneck
but when you go to the hardware store
and you get a coat and you get a
carhartt
carhartt is like
it's like the thing it's so like and
it's even like cute now like they've
like cutified it so now if you're in
college and you're in like a country
area the hot girls will wear like car
overalls and that's like they're like
cute now they have like carhartt louis
vuitton collabs
okay so when did car heart start
carhartt started in 1889. is this the
company you're talking about yes it's
coming from
it's bro i'm talking about building a
modern day thing you're talking about
this 1800s it's modern at this point
they've they've revolutionized it like
go to carhartt fall collection they've
got like a whole like cute kid like it
looks like a [__] like the kids are
wearing cars and vans and doing
everything
yeah bro for modernizing they totally
changed it it's like yeah carhartt is
like it's like it's like cool now i mean
it all it was like the workers man thing
just said where's the business
here's the mistake you're making first
of all you're yelling in the mic that's
a mistake for the podcast second second
of all
uh the mistake you're making he's
thinking that because something exists
that that's not how e-commerce works bro
economics i agree
i agree on clone crime it's just one oh
this works great i'll do it too thank
you take my piece of the pie and uh and
so
this working tells me nothing more than
that this is a even better idea for
somebody to go start look i agree
i agree to say oh does does this exist
like that's a dumb we always get those
dm's all the time why doesn't this exist
i'm like i don't know and it doesn't
matter it probably does yeah it probably
does it has to just do it or don't do it
but whether something does or doesn't it
doesn't matter but i just gotta check
you for a minute acting like you're like
coming up with this oh we should just do
figs for construction where like dude
there is an opportunity for somebody to
do this and by the way i'm looking at
their stuff
and they definitely have a lot of the
like like there's like this i don't even
know what you call this thing this like
you know it's like super yellow neon
jacket that's like you know you're not a
fireman but you wear this for some
reason so so uh they definitely have a
lot of the pieces but when i was going
down the rabbit hole of looking at what
what what are all the things that
basically outdoor workers wear whether
you're on you know you're in a shale
fracking you know
field or you're doing construction of
homes or you know it doesn't really
matter which which version of these but
it's like
there's a premium to be placed on super
rugged durable shoes but also mud shoes
but also
heavy jackets there's a towel that goes
on your neck that's a cooling towel
there's like this whole line of stuff
and the reason i think this might be
bigger and better than figs is if you
look at carhartt or duluth which are a
couple of companies that do this i think
they're both like 600 million plus in
annual sales duluth i looked up before
this there are 638 million in annual
sales it's only got a 500 million dollar
market cap so double the revenue of figs
so and you know what's duluth one-tenth
of the market cap duluth trading company
is another it's like carhartt um their
d2c business is growing 70
year-over-year so it's a it's obviously
like where where the action is versus
all their retail retail shops and so i
think you could come in i think you
could build a new brand in this space
and get acquired by delivery get
acquired by carhart these multi-billion
dollar companies as just another another
brand and you know there's an existing
d2c playbook that's like some
combination of facebook and instagram
ads influencers blah blah blah like
cutesy colors nice packaging all that
good stuff and i think you would want to
not do so cutesy here for for the rugged
wear but i think there's an opportunity
to
create a pretty iconic brand here i
wouldn't be surprised for somebody to do
to do yeti coolers
for
this carhartt brand right like i think
there's a yeti coolers type of brand to
be built in this space do you remember
land's end did you ever shop there as a
kid like your parents get like you don't
remember land monument in san francisco
uh
well yeah but
yeah it is but it's also like uh it's a
store like remember east bay as a kid
like easter everybody it lands then
so
it's american made clothing basically
you probably know what their boots are
so if you google lands in and then the
word duck it'll probably with it's
called the duck boot you definitely know
what that looks like it's like the
traditional like snow boot that you wear
as a kid and it's way popular now again
land zen i was just is another thing
it's just like duluth but yeah these
companies are trading for crazy low 1.5
billion dollars in sales 800 million
market cap
yeah i don't know why their multiples
suck so bad and that just kind of shows
me that figs is figs's story the thing i
talked about at the beginning like we
are you know starbucks for scrubs what
does that even [__] mean that means
nothing that's just words uh you know
we're nike we're lululemon we're kids
we're the next one
you know that's the story
yeah that's true it is just words
that's just words that's that's a good
diss to anybody at any time by the way
those are just words
immediate shutdown
yeah so i think they're you know i don't
know if they're overvalued or what but
they're definitely like trading outside
of their categories but you need to do
if you're gonna do this so construction
is interesting if land's end is
interesting because it was like
midwestern people but you have to do
like a brand and a niche where you feels
like us against the world so nurses feel
it's predominantly women so they already
have that little like segment of like
you know we're we're the underdog nurses
they probably think that they're
overworked underpaid so you got that
vibe going and it's like look we're
overworked we're underpaid this thing's
going to make us look good and actually
feel good that's we that's the least we
deserve you know what i mean so so you
ha it's been far better you got to go
with this angle of this group who feel
downtrodden brand that we talked about
that's the like america
grunt grunt style grunt work what is it
called i don't know what you're talking
about what do you what do you mean grail
no it's called grunt style so go to
gruntstyle.com i think we talked about
them
no what's that it's it's a us against
the world
um you know
proud for the we are proud of the police
we are people oh yeah these guys like
kill us proud of our country we we don't
you know vaccine you know you can stick
your vaccine here uh that's the vibe you
get when you go to grunt style and you
know it's very much a us against them
flags flying everywhere using american
ip basically to build the brand right
like here's a whiskey glass with two
cross rifles you know uh you know here's
a here's a here's a hat that looks like
it's been used for for you know 10 years
that's the type of stuff they said this
company crushes i think they do over 100
million in sales this company you know
alone so so i definitely think that us
versus them is a
it's a turbo charge when it comes to
marketing especially for especially for
d2c
um all right can i can we can i tell you
about an idea
so
this one has this is weird how i got to
this but basically i am interested like
my dream there's this guy named george
barber george barber in the early 1900s
his father started a dairy farm and
eventually george barber took it over
now george is either dead or in his like
90s i can't remember if he's dead or not
and he sold his dairy farm
based out of uh arkansas or alabama
barbarella i forget and he sold it for
like five or six hundred million dollars
and he crushed it and with a lot of that
money he opened this thing called barber
uh barb the barber museum and he created
a f1
race track in alabama and now um if you
are motors they do for motorcycle race
races they do it for uh f1 races for
nascar all types of stuff you can they
people from all over the world go to
watch races there and now he has got the
largest collection of motorcycles in the
world
and
the way that he set it up and is how the
way that a lot of these places set up so
have you ever been in like a small town
or or somewhere outside of san francisco
and you see like a car museum
and it's usually just like one person
that owns it it's just like a rich guy
who like sets it up but they okay let's
pretend i have yeah
too american for you but anyway they set
up a they set it up as non-profits
and so you can actually go and like see
their assets and stuff and so that
interested me anyway i just got really
interested because i want to own a [__]
load of cars i want to own like
historical memorabilia and the way that
you do it in a tax advantageous way is
you create a museum
and so i went down this little rabbit
hole have you heard of this company of
like basically i've i went down this
rabbit hole of places that you can go to
just to see interesting [__] and like
that's all you're doing you're just
sightseeing and you just leave and you
pay a little money and that just got me
interested
have you heard of meow wolf
meow wolf sounds familiar let me just
let me look it up what is it okay i put
their deck in here so i came across
their deck it's an old deck it's from
2017.
and what meow wolf is it started in 2008
in santa fe and it started as a
a a place to explore immersive art what
the hell does that mean like that like
that does a very who the hell knows that
could be anything and so basically what
it is is they would rent out these
massive old warehouses in santa fe and i
believe also in las vegas and they would
hire these artists who typically don't
make any money and they would say hey
come and make stuff here at our place
and we're going to create like
not quite a museum but almost like a
haunted house meets a museum meets
circus soleil
and
and you pay like 50 and you just walk
through and it's like an immersive
feeling
it's very challenging to explain but do
you see the pictures
yeah i'm looking at it you i think you
described it pretty well it's like like
the haunted house meets kind of like uh
a you know like some kind of rave i mean
it's like a museum
and it this this thing got me interested
because i was like i want to own like a
warehouse and finance it with this stuff
and just
collect cool [__] but uh guess how much
revenue these guys well guess how big
this business is
um let's just say 50 million a year
so they've raised like i believe 250
million dollars
and
they projected that just one of their
locations will make close to 40 million
a year in sales and they're having like
over a dozen
locations throughout the country is that
freaking nuts would you ever have
thought that how old is this is this
like was it started like in
like this yeah
oh wait okay
and so they opened one in las vegas in
2021 and they already sold 500 000
tickets for it then they're opening one
in denver they're uh going to austin
they're going to los angeles it's crazy
is this it's just a crazy crazy crazy
business and they said that
their projections for the the santa fe
location uh sorry their awesome
projections were 60 million in revenue
30 million in profit off one location
right what would you uh like how do they
get people to come to these what what is
it like what's the what's the marketing
to get to sell 500 000 of these tickets
like obviously there's some word of
mouth and stuff like that because it's a
pretty remarkable looking thing but
do these guys advertise like crazy do
you like you have their deck do you see
much about like their growth like i put
the deck in the i put the girl i put the
deck in the zen caster thing by the way
so you have it um but
oh it's locked uh i think i don't have
access
um and so yeah sorry about that and so
what they do is um
they team up so they teamed up with
santa fe the government of santa fe so
the government of santa fe was like
funneling people to them if you google
meow wolf santa fe they even put
together a
um
they even put together a like study an
economic study to show how much meow
wolf is helping the local area and so
they team up with with local governments
and that helps them like so like they
funnel people in there but i actually
don't know i don't think they do a
significant amount of paid advertising
i've not seen it anywhere right
yeah i think that uh i'm really into
this idea and by the way i see they have
a bunch of facebook ads on so i don't
know how much they're spending but they
definitely are running a bunch of
facebook ads and they look pretty cool
because the exhibits are cool so i'm
pretty into this idea um and i feel like
there's a whole bunch of different
niches you could go with this that are
like hyper um have like hyper engagement
and so i think there's
you know if you just go city by city and
you say all right what what could i do
that's a pop up here that would um be
able to consistently draw people so i
think i told you about this once but
there was this um
what's it called two-bit circus are you
familiar with two-bit circuits no what's
that so so look it up it's um
it's like the number two you know like
two
two-bit circus
i think this is the name of it so
there's a guy who um
[Music]
okay so the guy who invented chuck e
cheese his name's nolan whatever his
name is his son or grandson i don't know
which one um bush some bushel bushnell
or whatever their names are
his son or grandson created this thing
called two-bit circus right so so
grandpa maybe or dad creates chucky
cheese this person created stupid circus
and what 2-bit circus was was basically
like a traveling
pop-up museum like this but it was all
for like interactive um like kind of
like technology so like imagine like
like if this is like kind of like a
haunted house vibe this is like you know
you're in the year 2050 watch this like
move your hand this laser will move and
follow you oh okay kids come into this
room look at this like with one small
mirror you can reflect light and create
this like crazy thing or put on this vr
thing and play dance dance revolution
you'll feel like you're in space dancing
or whatever right like just a whole
bunch of high-tech kind of like
attractions um that existed and they
would take this from city to city and
the video made it look like
dude i want to take my kids here this
looks like so much fun and unlike those
other ones that have like a fixed
location this would pop up a tent and
they would run this thing and in one
weekend they would have like 60 000
people in the bay area come through um
you know like in a four-day period or
whatever and then they would like pack
up the tent and they would go hit the
road and i thought this is like a genius
idea and the guy who i knew who was
working with them he was kind of like an
exec there
he was like dude this is a it's an
amazing product he's like but uh you
know the founders have kind of like
shiny object syndrome they you know they
want to do this and then like uh you
know like whoever like you know facebook
will say oh we want to do a private
exhibit and they'll be like cool we're
going to create the most epic thing ever
or obama wants to have us for a party so
like hey everybody like forget the like
systematized process that we could just
grow repeatedly like let's blow
everyone's mind with this thing at
burning man and like just let's let's
create something nobody's ever seen and
they would go do that he's like dude
it's like so annoying like we just can't
stay focused but what ever since i saw
this idea like i don't know when this
was seven eight years ago i first heard
this idea this two-bit circus thing i
just thought it was such a cool smart
idea and i was so i'm shocked i don't
see more of this where this traveling
circus where it's a pop-up tent that
maybe leverages science or technology
because i think parents care to take
their kids there and i think science and
technology naturally make for great
exhibits and demos and like learning
learning plus like visual stimulation
like if you just think back to like
science fair or a science class with a
volcano exploding or whatever like
basically that on steroids and i feel
like that's a pretty big thing but you
know these are hard businesses to do i
would never go try to do one of these
because uh yeah they're hard but they
seem i don't like events either but this
is a little bit different than an event
but uh
it does seem cool speaking of events let
me tell you about something so i got
dinner uh the other day with jason my
friend who runs this thing called
blockworks and he had just hosted an
event any and i asked them for i go can
you tell me numbers so i could talk
about the pod because i think it's
interesting so scroll down to the bottom
and you'll see we're scroll down past
where it says digital asset summit you
see it yep i see it okay so uh this is
jason he's got this company called
blockworksblackworks.com it's like the
hustle but for uh
crypto
um so two day conference that he just
hosted recently uh
it did uh two million in revenue he said
he told me it did about 50 in profit 800
attendees ticket costs one to two
thousand dollars
and uh
and then they're doing another event he
has another event coming out in may of
so uh uh uh in about what's that six
months
eight months and their goal is eight
million in revenue with five thousand
attendees and then most recently he did
a and a digital or this is not even a
physical conference right
uh the eight million dollar one is and
the digital asset one yeah it's it's
it's uh
like you go there you see people yeah
yeah it's live okay and then he most
recently did one called uh i think it's
called brenton woods and that's for
where he basically he had 200 people
come and or maybe like 100 people come
and they were basically large asset
managers and all they did was talked
about crypto and uh
he it did close to
a million in revenue and they only had
four sponsors and it seemed like a
pretty sick event and i was just talking
to him and we were at dinner and i was
just i was just like just tell me
everything that everyone said like what
are the takeaways and i thought a few
things one
i think jason's only 26. so kudos to
this [__] guy for building this
business
uh and second what a great hack i mean
just to like get the it gets get the
intel from the best minds in the world
and like he's smart but he's just the
he's not smart enough to predict the
future like you know
you could if you sit around with 200
people who are asset managers for you
know the oregon state pension fund
things like that right um pretty amazing
that he pulled this off
yeah this job shout out to him this is
like well this is what i would call
crushing it right you have this new wave
of technology and you say all right
i'm gonna go be the hustle or be whoever
i'm gonna be the hustle for for crypto
and then on the events side it's
basically a win-win win right you do one
of these events you make money
you get to rub shoulders with all the
most interesting people that's going to
open up a whole bunch of other doors
that you don't even need to think about
ahead of time and then all of them are
going to like think highly of block work
subscribe to it pay for your premium
stuff like tell their you know tell
their employees about it that sort of
thing as they go and in doing so you're
promoting that you're evangelizing
crypto amongst these like really wealthy
people who will start betting on it and
it'll grow crypto which will just make
your business more popular plus your
individual holdings more popular so it's
like win win on top a win for a 26 year
old i think that's very very impressive
um i think by the way this is a thing
anybody can replicate not just in crypto
okay this is like let's say i'll call
this a home run
and it's in crypto but i think there's a
lot of people listening to this that
would be happy with you know half or or
a third or a fourth of the type of
success of this and i think you could
achieve that with in any profession so
it's like take any niche whether it's
like gaming or like in venture capital
right like we have rolling funds like
why isn't somebody just doing this with
all the vcs constantly like i know
chamath tweeted this out the other day
he goes hey uh yeah solo solo gps that
are out there if i organize like an
event or retreat for all of us to get to
know each other hey we're all solo gps
right but if you just said new vcs right
you could be at the bottom you could be
some associate somewhere or not even
have a job in venture capital and you
could arrange
the kind of like next gen the next wave
vc thing where you invite all the new
people to vc
to this badass retreat you know in wine
country or wherever where it's like
we're all off the grid we're going to do
some cool stuff there's going to be some
speakers you're glamping whatever it is
you would be able to make a couple
million dollars network with every
single person you want to and you'd kind
of have that little mini industry in the
palm of your hands i've seen people do
this with digital marketing and every
niche
there's this guy uh or our friend nick
went to went to this thing the other day
and it's got a great name it's called
capital camp
and i believe it's in columbia missouri
where i'm from and i forget the guy oh
brett brett started it i think
brett b sure yeah yeah i don't know if
he runs it or what the deal is anymore i
think they started it yeah
they started it and it was like it's
hard to explain what the niche is but i
totally know what it is or who would go
but it's basically at this point we
talked last week about the circle of
people on twitter who tweet about
finance and tech and real estate it's
kind of this group of people who talk
about real estate and sweaty and uh blue
collar businesses on twitter and they
all go to capital camp and it's like ten
thousand dollars i think private equity
is like the bucket but then like nick's
not really private equity he's like self
storage uh but like you know he'll go to
capital camp so that's you're right it's
basically private equity is the big
umbrella and then like any kind of
sweaty business or uh like cash flowing
things or reset real estate business
kind of non you know non-fancy
fancy-schmancy tech basically and it
costs 10 grand to go and nick went and
he said it was totally worth it and and
the people who i know who go they say
it's totally worth it and they're going
to go back every year
and
it probably made a good i bet you it
made uh it probably made a little bit of
profit but in a fair amount of revenue
yeah i'm gonna spin up like a mini one
of these um i've one that i'm gonna do
for club ltv which is my like e-commerce
likes all store owners who do between
one and a hundred million in revenue um
basically i'm gonna do a retreat for
them which is just my own excuse to do
something fun
i'm not really going to try to like make
a profit off of it but as long as they
cover all the costs of hosting
everything that'll be great and so i'm
going to do this in the e-commerce niche
but i just feel like you could do this
across like just in the two two of the
camps that we were in right uh startup
investing and and i'm in e-commerce i
think you could do this in either one of
those and have
you know have fun profits big build your
network all that stuff it just takes it
just takes hustle which unfortunately i
don't have that much hustle anymore all
my hustle goes to my kids now there's no
no you will soon i think let me tell you
something really quick
i ha so you're you're you've been angel
investing longer than i have um
uh i would not claim that i'm like
nearly as good as you or some of our
friends but i um
two things i did i did these two things
in 2019
um one of them just
50xed
nice and one of them just uh
12x
amazing on paper or or
exited already i'm paid actually i know
one of them the the the 50x i know it's
on paper the other one paper yeah
they're both on paper so they're not
real but i
i i feel good because because this whole
angel investing thing you just
you spend you spend
you spend and i'm like is this ever
going to work i'm just spending all of
this money it's just leaving my bank
account i don't even know if it's there
and when you count it as part of your
net worth like i pretty much don't i'm
like oh this sucks what's going to
happen
and
we'll see like
if it starts actually hatching those
eggs are hatching okay so let me tell
you i have something related to this so
i texted a friend
who i won't say their name um but
they're they're an investor they've been
doing this much longer than me angel
investing seed investing that sort of
thing vc personally all they've done it
all do i know them
i don't think so and um and so they
they've done very very well bunch of
eggs a bunch of winners that are like
public companies that we know about
which is like you know the
that's the
that's like as high as it goes basically
and so multiple winners like that so i
texted him i said i say hey i gotta ask
you a question i said feel free to
just brush this off if you don't want to
tell me
but
i'm not asking to be nosy i'm asking
because i'm trying to weigh out my
options here and i said you know in
terms of investing
you've basically done as good as anyone
as good as i could hope to do right like
i would say you have done extremely well
it's kind of like best case scenario
type of
outcome and
what does that mean personally in terms
of what you end up making i said here's
what my guess here's what my guess is
tell me if i'm if i'm on point or if i'm
off and i basically said i thought
can you can you give all the numbers
because the person's anonymous yeah i'm
going to say the numbers so i said
i think that
you probably will make 15 to 30 million
dollars
over a kind of 10 to 15 year period
of investing so it takes probably
probably you don't see any of it till 10
plus years but between 10 and 20 years
you're gonna make i don't know 20 to 30
million dollars
and that's that payday at the end of the
day and i think along the way you're
making half a million bucks cushy kind
of like off the management fees your
salary
i said is that about wait oh this person
has a fund
they have done many things so they've
invested personally as an angel they've
been a vc at a big fund they now i think
kind of like our solo gp maybe have
their own fun maybe it's personal i
don't really know i don't know all the
details but they've done both i said
either way along the way yeah they're
not it's not i'm not saying from their
personal money they've had other
people's money right opm they've always
been using opm or they've definitely
been using opm for a lot of it right
maybe some of it was angel money but now
it's a lot of opm so i said all right um
am i right uh so first like let me let
me ask you to guess
do you think they said that's right
that's low or that's high okay so 10
years they've been doing it
let's call it 15 years
they've been doing it for 15 15 years
and they've been using other people's
money
for most of it yeah how much money did
they invest
i can't tell you
over under 100.
um
[Music]
let's say they they're they're a seed
investor they're early they're early
stages i understand i would say i didn't
check that might be like as low as 100k
and maybe high as 500k or a minute and
it was their fault a full-time job for
10 years yeah this is what they do my
guess is way above 15.
that i'm low my guess was low i would
guess like 40 or 50.
yeah so
you're right that my guess was low so
what they said was they go yes it should
be much more than that but it's hard to
say because a lot of it's still a liquid
they go uh
they go it should look more like hundred
fifty to two hundred no way
[Music]
um yeah and this person this person
they're not a boaster but they are one
of the best of the best meaning their
portfolio you could stack up against
pretty much anybody like obviously if
you hit one like you know i was you know
the lead investor in google okay yeah
you're gonna have like the outside but
i'm saying this person has
multiple
like you know almost i don't know
more than five somewhere somewhere
around 10 like known big winners and so
i'm like okay cool but you know you
don't know what round how much they
invested like in each of those right so
look at that look at the message is that
the person no that's not the person so
um
so so basically i was like whoa that
okay that's a lot more and have they
made money along the way other than
their management fee or their salary
uh well just like you know the exits as
they as they come through as they do
trickle in yeah so like you know first
five years not much next five years some
next five years a whole bunch but you're
recycling and you're reinvesting so you
know you always have kind of a new batch
of companies that you're waiting you
know you want these things to age 10
years
for you to go get a big win out of them
um you always have a new vintage right
when i did 20 20 i want to i want to go
uncork that bottle in 2030 and see how
it tastes
oh my god
sorry uh
is your ringtone a duck
yeah it's [__] up
country [__] dude that sounds like the
hunting duck call you used to attract
animals
i don't know i just liked it i just
wanted to be a duck i just like them
i just like that noise
um
so wait so this person but are they
investing their own money
so so what i told them i go i go wow so
that's basically like you started you're
like a founder of a billion dollar
company if you're gonna net 100 million
to 200 million dollars
uh at the end of this that kind of like
this journey this career i said you know
it sounds like it happens a little bit
slower
but you're making more money and way
easier way less way easier it's way
easier like way easier not even close
yeah exactly and what did they say um
they were like i mean they were like
they're so humble that they're kind of
like trying to deflect they were like
well you know tell me how you're
thinking about it so i can help you here
right because they're like you know what
are you asking me all this [__] for and
like
you know i don't enough about me i've
done well but like
let me help you if you're trying to get
some help out of this and all i really
wanted to know was like what's the size
of the prize if you knock this out of
the park and like what's the real what's
the real nuts like what really comes
through at the end of the day like for
somebody who's because you know any time
you go into something there's like you
know you could i can go read about real
estate i'm not a big real estate
investor i can go read about real estate
i could talk oh yeah you're gonna make
this much gross this much net you've got
to cap rate blah blah it's like then you
talk to somebody's been doing it for 25
years like yeah but like you're you know
all these hidden costs you're not
accounting for all this extra heartache
you're not accounting for all this extra
stress and then you know one of the four
buildings you know burns up in a fire
and you have to account for that loss so
there's always the reality first what
was your takeaway though like what did
you do what did he what did you what i
wasn't looking i i wasn't like trying to
make a decision on anything i was just
thinking where's your head at though
my head is basically like surprised
frankly that that it can be that big um
and again this person's not a boaster
i'm pulling this information out i think
they were just doing me a favor of being
honest about what they think this nets
in the end and i was like wow the
reality though is do i believe i can
have the same hit rate as them no
uh like i think they have had like an ex
they have extreme skill and extreme luck
and so it's like okay and they do this
full time right so it's like i'm not
planning for that but i like knowing
what
what winning looks like today or what is
the top top range of winning look like
uh so i was pretty impressed by that so
that was kind of my my takeaway or
something you know something i learned
kind of from i don't remember what you
were talking about before you talk about
your your your multiples and so
yeah it's pretty pretty impressive but i
would say you know that that's on a
large amount of invest capital i should
also say that you know it's much more
capital than i'm investing because
they've done it for longer and they
write bigger checks
yeah it's way more boring but it's
definitely way easier
and that's the show right
yeah all right we're out of here
[Music]
never looking back